سبعه ايام هذا احد شوارع ام درمان عوده
مؤقته للحياه ربما وفرصه للجلوس في اجواء
هادئه نسبيا لا يتخللها اصوات الحرب
اما هنا ففرصه ايضا لكسب الرزق وجوله عمل
حرم منها لشهر واكثر
بينما هذه السيده وجدت متنفسا بعد صراع
اسقاها مراره الحاجه
شيء من اساسيات الحياه عادت متواضعه هنا
وفي المنازل انفراجات ايضا من الهدنه امس
نحن امس الحمد لله الكهرباء رجعت انقطع
كهرباء وشويه اليوم
الثالث والحمد لله هذا لكن في حذف شديد
عوده بحذر تفاؤل عام قابله سكان اخرون
شهدوا على خرق للهدنه بسماعهم لاصوات
المدافع بعد التحسب
الرعب فينا وفي اولادنا
وخلونا زي ما دايرينا نحنا هدنه ان ثبتت
هشاشتها سيواجه طرفان نزاع عقوبات امريكيه
توعد بها وزير الخارجيه الامريكي في حال
لم يلتزم باتفاق وقف اطلاق النار
غيداء السالم العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات